as the Senate convenes this afternoon we
found our nation facing too grave and
serious choices one concerns our unity
at home and the future of our
Constitution the other involves our
strength abroad and the security of our
homeland both situations demand serious
sober treatment from Congress both
require that we put enduring national
interests ahead of the factionalism and
short-termism
the founding fathers warned us about but
unfortunately as president serious this
is in short supply
lately in very shortly short supply from
the determined critics of President
Trump and our nation of course is worse
for it last Thursday the United States
took decisive action to end the
murderers scheming of Iran's chief
terrorists kwasind Salamone salah
manning had been spent numerous years
masterminding attacks on american
service members and our partners
throughout the Middle East and expanding
Iran's influence despite sanctions
despite prohibitions by the UN Security
Council he roamed throughout the region
with impunity his hands bought the blood
of more American service members than
anyone else alive hundreds of American
families had buried loved ones because
of him veterans have learned to live
with permanent injuries inflicted by his
terrorists and in Iraq and in Syria and
beyond the entire region felt the
effects of his evil tactics we should
welcome his death and it's complication
of Tehran's terrorism industrial complex
but we must remain vigilant and soberly
prepare for even further aggression now
it is completely appropriate the
decision would generate interest and
questions from this body we can and we
should learn more about the intelligence
and thinking that led to this operation
and the plan to defend American
personnel and interests in the wake of
it
I'm glad the administration will hold an
all Senators briefing on Wednesday
it'll be led by secretary of defense for
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
general Milley
secretary of state Pompeo and CIA
director hospital unfortunately in this
toxic political environment some of our
colleagues rushed to blame our own
government before even knowing the facts
rushed to split hairs about intelligence
before being briefed on it and rushed to
downplay sulle money's evil while
presenting our own President as the
villain soon after the news broke one of
our distinguished colleagues made a
public statement that rightly calls solo
mining a murderer
and then amazingly walk that message
back when the far-left objected to the
factual statement since then I believe
all her criticism is directed at our own
president another of our Democratic
colleagues has been thinking out loud
about Middle East policy on social media
mere days before President Trump's
decision this Senator tore into the
White House for what he described as
weakness and inaction no one fears us he
complained Trump has rendered America
impotent in the Middle East but since
the strike a complete 180
that same senators harshly criticized
our own president for getting tough
ludicrously he and others on the Left
have accused the administration of
committing an illegal act and equated
the removal of this terrorist leader
with a foreign power assassination of
our own Secretary of Defense well here's
what one Oxford had to say about it
jeh Johnson President Obama's own former
and general counsel and Secretary of
Homeland Security here's what he said if
you believe everything that our
government is saying about general
Soleimani he was a lawful military
objective and the president under his
constitutional authority as
commander-in-chief had ample domestic
legal authority to take him out without
without an additional congressional
authorization whether he was a terrorist
or a general in a military force that
was engaged in armed attacks against our
people
he was a lawful military objective
that's the former secretary of homeland
security in the Obama administration jeh
Johnson an expert on these things and
our former colleague Joe Lieberman who
ran for vice-president on the Democratic
ticket in 2000 wrote this morning that
in their uniformly skeptical or negative
reactions to solo Mounties death
Democrats are creating the risk that the
US will be seen as acting and speaking
with less authority abroad at this
important time that's how former
Democratic senators seize it look the
Senate is supposed to be the chamber
where overheated partisan passions give
way to sober judgment
can we not at least wait until we know
the facts
can we not maintain a shred just a shred
of national energy for five minutes or
five minutes before deepening the
partisan trenches
most Democrats distaste for this
president dominate every thought they
expressed and every decision they make
is that really the seriousness that this
situation deserves the full Senate will
be briefed on Wednesday I expect the
Committees of oversight will also
conduct hearings and the Senators will
have plenty of opportunities
to discuss our interest and policies in
the regions so I would urge my
colleagues to bring a full awareness of
the facts mindfulness of the long
history of Iran's aggression toward the
United States and its allies and a sober
understanding of the threat Iran
continues to pose could we at least
remember we're all Americans first and
we're all in this together now meantime
at this dangerous time House Democrats
continue to pave play political games
with their partisan impeachment of the
commander in chief last year House
Democrats conducted the least thorough
most rushed most unfair impeachment
inquiry in history for weeks
Democrats they said they could not wait
for due process could not conduct a
normal or fair inquiry because we're
moving the president from office was so
incredibly urgent incredibly urgent
well the unserious nacinda
[Music]
even more obvious now because speaker's
Pelosi is now sitting on the articles
she claimed were so very urgent she's
delayed this indefinitely so that the
architects of the failed house process
can look for ways to reach over here
into the Senate and dictate our process
as well Democrats have tried to insist
that the Senate deviate from the
unanimous bipartisan precedent set in
the 1999 trial of President Clinton and
write new rules for president trunk
they've tried to pre-commit the Senate
to redoing House Democrats slapdash work
for them and pursuing avenues that
Sherman Schiff himself didn't bother to
pursue mr. president the Senate has a
unanimous bipartisan precedent for when
to handle mid-trial questions such as
witnesses
in the middle of the trial which when
that was done the last time and that's
the way it should be done this time
in 1999 every single US senator agreed
to establish basic parameters for the
start of the trial up front and reserve
mid-trial questions such as witnesses
until later the vote was a hundred to
nothing that was good enough for
President Clinton so it ought to be good
enough for President Trump
fair is fair House Democrats hunger to
break at our Senate precedents just like
they broke their own house presidents
could not be more telling but the Senate
does not just Bob along on the currents
of every news cycle the house may have
been contempt to scrub their own norms
to hurt President Trump but that is not
the Senate even with a process this
constitutionally serious even with
tensions rising in the Middle East House
Democrats are treating impeachment like
a political toy like a political toy
treating their own effort to remove our
commander in chief like some frivolous
game these bizarre stunts do not serve
our Constitution or our national
security they erode both my Democratic
colleagues should not plow away American
unity in some bizarre intramural
competition to see who dislikes the
president more they should not disdain
our Constitution by rushing through a
purely partisan impeachment process and
then toying around with it
governing a serious business
the American people deserve better a lot
better
No